[Music]
I want another host daughter
Jonah just forgot
[Music]
this is the feeling I've been searching
for my entire life
and I want to know what happened that
night I need to show that I'm a lone
fierce she-wolf
move the cat out
Winterfell is yours your grace
[Music]
everybody it's Charlie we had to freak
out about this new game of Thrones
footage HBO slipped out a game of
Thrones Season 8 teaser while the Golden
Globes were happening I wasn't expecting
them to drop any kind of big trailer or
anything like that this early in the
year but before they do stuff like that
they usually drop smaller teasers like
this so it's just great scene of Jon and
Daenerys arriving at Winterfell and
giving you the sense for the tone of how
the first episode is gonna start out
well do a new round of the book giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video so big thing happening here this
is actually the opening scene from
season 8 episode 1 they already revealed
that a little while ago in a big
Entertainment Weekly spread they give us
an idea for what the character dynamics
are going to be this scene pretty much
tells you everything you need to know
about what the relationships are gonna
be like when they first meet up like you
see Sansa with those cold eyes she's
already pretty tall ik sophie turner in
real life is taller than Kit Harington
and this is about how tall Emilia Clarke
is next to Kit Harington so Sansa is
going to tower over Daenerys literally
and figuratively just because she's so
unhappy
with the current state of affairs in the
fact that Jon Snow is in a relationship
with her a sexual relationship and that
he bent the knee I've already done a
couple breakdown to the big beets that
they've already revealed but for the
most part you know you chart the
timeline there's only six episodes the
first big battle with the night king and
the White Walkers at Winterfell is
probably going to happen sometime around
Episode three so there's only so much
bickering they can do and if you think
about how much that lasted during season
seven like it was a little bit during
episode 1 a little bit in episode 2 when
everyone got really pissed at Jon for
wanting to go lead to treat with
Daenerys then Sansa chilled out once Jon
gave her control of Winterfell which is
sort of his endorsement of her ability
to leave like here it's in your hands
but because the North remembers there's
also those feelings being dredged up by
the northern Lords because of what
happened during Robert's rebellion in
the Mad King now his daughter is on
their doorstep so they'll be a little
fun with that in the first episode so
you can kind of see Sansa and a lot of
the lords to the north on one side of
the table then Jon Daenerys the
wildlings anyone that's fought with
Daenerys so far and saw what happened
north of the wall on the other side of
the table like we don't care about any
of this politicking we just need
defend the realm against this giant army
this head itself but just look at that
long pause in the look that Daenerys
gives Sansa after she senses all the
shade on her face looking down on her
Winterfell is yours your grace she
pauses there for a beat and gives a bit
of a fake smile like there's so much
tension going on in this moment and you
look at Jon's face and you look at
Brienne's face and you look at Sir Jorah
Mormont's face and each one of them has
a different expression Jon Snow knows
nothing looks like he isn't thinking
about any kind of problem between the
two of them Brienne and Jorah Mormont
look like they're both kind of worried
about what's going to happen in Jorah
Mormont has not been back since he was
banished by Ned Stark so this is a big
reunion for him too I'm sure I'll have
some small moment with a little bear but
the whole thing with Jorah Mormont in
the first season is that he was trying
to curry favor so that he could come
back to the realm that's why he was
working for Robert to inform on what was
going on with Daenerys in her marriage
to Khal Drogo I don't think I've done a
Jorah Mormont video in a while but he's
also one of the other really interesting
characters that's not necessarily a main
character it has so much stuff going on
when he comes back to Winterfell that
they have to address that's why the
episodes are gonna be so much longer
than normal episode so they can take the
time to have all those moments so like
Jaime for instance already has a couple
big reunions he's got to meet with
Tyrion he's got to meet with Brienne
again and he's got to have a reunion
with bran which is probably gonna be the
most fun of them all but there's just
one character John has to have a reunion
with Sansa we've already seen a little
bit of a teaser for that I think that
this new scene with them arriving
happens right after that like John walks
through the gate with Daenerys in their
small little group he walks up to greet
Sansa first then turns around and says
this is Daenerys Stormborn introducing
her she walks up with Sir Jorah there's
the wide shot of Winterfell with the
logo over it but I can't tell if this is
new footage or if it's just old footage
that they've repurposed from season 7
episode 1 because it looks very similar
and you don't see any of the Dothraki
you don't see any of Daenerys dragons in
here and even though it's just
speculation I think it's pretty
plausible that Jon would advise her not
to come through the gates with a giant
show of force like you don't see any of
the Dothraki in the background here this
shot anyway so all of them are probably
just waiting outside somewhere but I
cannot wait to see how everyone at
Winterfell reacts when Daenerys flies in
with her dragons even if she does just
land them outside the castle wall
also not sure if this shot of drogon
riding into frame with the do--the Rocky
is a repeat from season 7 episode 4 in
the field of fire or if it's actual new
footage from them down near King's
Landing because winter has come as far
south as King's Landing I would be very
surprised if there's this much greenery
down there right now most of the bigger
reunions I think will be happening first
like Arya John is a really big reunion
that'll happen relatively early in the
episode if it's not happening also in
the courtyard here because they're
trying to mirror that opening scene from
season 1 episode 1 in the pilot when
Robert first rode in and you get to meet
all of them like Robert walks up needs
Ned Stark they hug it out then you meet
Cersei then you meet all the other
Lannisters for those are you asking
about the actual big season 8 trailer I
talked a little about that during my
Sandor Clegane Hound Season 8 promo that
I posted a little while ago earlier
today so I'll link that at the end of
this but for the most part not expecting
that first real big trailer till the end
of the month but what'll probably happen
next is is because we have all this
stark stuff happening at Winterfell as
they'll do a similar type of teaser with
a little bit of footage for what's going
on down at King's Landing with Cersei
but she has the golden company coming
Euron Greyjoy is coming back so there's
still a lot of stuff happening down
there while you're having all these
reunions up at Winterfell and they start
to plan for the attack of the night king
and the White Walkers so just a reminder
that everything that we've seen all the
footage is from the opening scene in
season 8 episode 1 the difference in the
trailers that they drop is that they
usually contain footage from all over
the season so you'll get stuff from the
later episodes too the only thing
they'll probably try to hold back or
like the really big twist in the footage
from the finale just to try and keep it
as much of a mystery as possible
although I think by the time we get
there we'll have a pretty good sense for
where things are headed there's a whole
bunch of other season 8 promos that I
haven't posted yet so I'll work through
those in the next couple of weeks leave
all your requests in the comments below
or if you have any specific questions
about the footage in this video but I
know you have a lot of questions about
the Watchmen footage that they drop - I
don't think that's gonna drop either -
like August maybe sometime during the
summer but because it's in this trailer
this is their 2019 trailer it'll
probably happen relatively quickly after
Game of Thrones airs because I think
Watchmen is supposed to be like their
next big genre series until they start
dropping episodes for the Game of
Thrones prequel and we probably
won't get footage for that until after
Game of Thrones season eight is done
they'll be filming the pilot for the
prequel series sometime in February I
think but what'll happen is is most of
my Game of Thrones videos between now
and April will be about the main series
if there's any like real big news or any
footage or anything for the prequel
series I'll do separate videos for that
so be sure to leave your requests if you
have special videos you want me to make
right now all I really know about the
Watchmen series is is that Jeremy Irons
is playing an older version of
Ozymandias so based on how old he is
that gives you a pretty good idea for
how much time has passed since the
events of the original Watchmen movie so
this is taking place many years after
that but separate from Game of Thrones
they will be doing a lot of previews for
this because they want to hype it up as
much as possible before their premiere
right now I am planning on doing episode
videos for Watchmen the same way I would
do for Westworld or for Game of Thrones
or any other HBO series but we got a lot
of stuff coming I'll name a new giveaway
winner when I post a new game of thrones
click here for my new cleganebowl season
8 promo and click here for my playlist
of all the other Game of Thrones promos
I've posted thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
you